we can talk now to the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis thank you very
much for being with us um i'm keen to
kind of deep dive into the northern
ireland uh situation in a moment but
just to start with ukraine
um two british men uh sentenced to death
uh we're told after being falsely
accused of being mercenaries in ukraine
it's alongside a moroccan national as
well we're talking to a friend of his
later on the programme
what is the government doing to try and
help these men well i mean it's the fact
that
the foreign secretary said it's
effectively a kind of sham trial really
uh and i think it it backs up what we've
all seen is this abhorrent uh process
that putin has followed in terms of an
unwarranted attack on ukraine in the
general way that putin's regime is
acting it's pretty despicable actually
we're working with the ukrainians these
are
people who are serving us in the
ukrainian armed forces they're protected
there from the geneva convention and i
know the foreign secretary is in close
contact with her counterparts in ukraine
to do everything we can to support the
individuals and support and work with
ukraine to get the right outcome to this
well this this disgraceful situation but
it but it sums up pretty much the uphold
way that putin and his regime have acted
over the last few months
you know as you say it's a show trial
they've been falsely accused of being
mercenaries
is there anything we can actually do
well as i say it's difficult to go into
the details of any particular case and
obviously particularly that consent of
the individuals but the foreign
secretary the prime minister i know are
fully engaged on this uh working with
ukrainians because they were serving
ukrainian armed forces and therefore
they are protected by the geneva
convention something that all
governments around the world
have respected for for decades now and
it's something that russia should
respect as well but as we've seen as i
say we've seen putin act in a pretty
abhorrent and illegal way consistently
over the last few months so we've got to
keep that pressure on and do everything
we can support not just these families
but actually everybody who's fighting
for uh for democracy actually in ukraine
i guess that's the issue there isn't you
said that putin is prepared to act
illegally given that you know is there
something we can do or not or not well
we've got to keep the pressure on we've
got to work through this in the proper
way and that's working with our partners
in ukraine because as i say they were
serving officers in the ukrainian armed
forces we will be continuing to do that
i know the foreign secretary as i say is
in close contact with her counterparts
there to do everything we can as i say
to support not just those individuals
but actually
the wider people of ukraine in the
battle that they're they're they're
dealing with with uh putin's uh invasion
we're seeing some pretty um worrying
reports coming out of the fighting
currently happening in ukraine are in
the donbass and it reports that they're
running out of ammunition heavy losses
of course the difficult phase of the war
do you think the tide is starting to
turn against ukraine
well but one of the things we've seen is
ukraine has consistently been able to
hold up
its defense and to actually put pressure
on russia and slow rushes advance and
actually in some cases at times push
russia back a little bit we're doing our
bit to help obviously we're leading that
international coalition and putting the
support in there again it's the great
credit the defense secretary and the
prime minister they were leading the way
from the very beginning and getting
support into ukraine in northern ireland
we're doing our bit in that the end laws
and star street which is now coming into
ukraine are developed and produced in
belfast and i've been very proud to be
able to go and visit and see the team
there and people in northern ireland are
very proud of what belfast is doing
we've got to keep up that support for
the people
weapons do you think well we're
continuing to send those defensive
lethal weapons support into ukraine and
i think there is an element of just that
general support of the western world and
we in the uk particularly leading on
that can give ukraine gives them the
confidence that the world is behind them
that they are in the right to defend a
sovereign democracy and we've got to
stand by that okay
now you of course are publishing
legislation tomorrow on the northern
ireland uh protocol this of course is
part of the brexit deal that this
government negotiated
is it going to contain notwithstanding
clauses now these clauses of course
would effectively override parts of the
withdrawal agreement well i'm not going
to go into the specifics of something
before we publish its parliament but you
are right we're going to be publishing
legislation tomorrow i would just say of
course notwithstanding clauses have a
particular legal meaning that give
clarity to courts if they come to
interpret
things down the line but as i say what
we're looking to do is fix the problems
we're seeing with the protocol it's
around how the protocol has been
implemented the lack of flexibility
we've seen from the eu over the last
year and a half of trying to negotiate
with them where they've not really moved
at all and in fact at the moment what
the eu proposed would send us backwards
from where we are today that isn't
sustainable and every political party in
northern ireland wants to see changes to
the protocol we want to fix it so it
works for people in northern ireland and
respects all aspects of the belfast good
friday agreement which at the moment
isn't happening um
so
on the north withstanding clauses you
say that they would provide clarity to
the courts effectively by
overriding or changing parts of the
original agreement what we're going to
set out tomorrow is a piece of
legislation that will rectify the issues
that are there in the protocol we've
always said there has to be an agreement
between us and the eu we've got to
respect the question the question is
whether will it contain these
notwithstanding as i said i'm not going
to detail something before we publish
its department that's the right thing to
do we'll publish the parliament the bill
tomorrow what the bill will do is
restore all aspects of the belfast good
friday agreement there's three strains
a year ago a court in northern ireland
high court found that the protocol does
abide by the good friday agreement so
i'm not really sure that the answer no
that's no let's be close with him sorry
that's wrong what the court found a year
ago is that it doesn't override certain
aspects of the belfast good friday
agreement in one part what isn't correct
though is the belfast good friday group
has three strands both north south which
at the moment is under pressure and
isn't working the north south
ministerial councils do not happen at
the moment that is not functioning east
west we know there are issues great
britain to northern and over 200
businesses have stopped supplying
northern ireland and their certain
products we can't move to northern
ireland despite them being for
consumption or use within the united
kingdom single markets that isn't
working as strand one the fundamental
part of that is the institution of
stormont that is not functioning at the
moment there is no executive working so
all three strands are either broken or
under pressure that's the very thing
that the protocol was setting out to
protect it's not doing it so it's right
that we actually repair that okay now
the last time you tried to unilaterally
change the brexit deal to help trade in
northern ireland that's in september
2020
you acknowledge that that will break the
law in your words in a specific and
limited way
will the legislation tomorrow break the
law so couple things so three things
actually first of all the legislation
will outline tomorrow is within the law
what we're going to do is lawful and it
is correct but just two other really
important points when we set that out
when i set that out in late 2020 the
point we were making was we were giving
primacy to the belfast good friday
agreement it was about protecting that
over and above what was at that point an
incomplete withdrawal agreement but i
would also say we of course took
unilateral action in the spring of last
year when we extended the grace periods
and those extensions are still in place
something you wouldn't agree at the time
but has recognized was actually
important you say you said that this is
acting within the law
how can we be so sure that it isn't
going to break the law are you going to
publish the legal advice that's based on
well we're setting out the legal basis
on which we are um taking forward this
legislation i think when people see what
is the league what is that when people
say what is illegal when people see the
legislation tomorrow they will see and
we will be setting out our legal
position on this people will see that
what we are proposing resolves the key
issues within the protocol that don't
work so what is the legal basis on which
you're publishing this advice well we
have to actually outline what we're
doing in a context that is about
protecting the integrity of the belfast
good friday group we've always said the
attorney general back in 2019 was very
clear belfast's good fine agreement
absolute has paramount importance to the
uk government it's the primacy it's the
original thing it's an international
agreement between us and the irish
government that we will always give
first priority to i'm just trying to
work out just to get onto the law on to
whether or not this is within the law
because for many people this is really
important you're very confidently
asserting
that this is within the law so
will you publish the are you committing
to publish publishing the advice on
which that is given well as i'm saying
first of all you'll see the latest
people will see the legislation smiles
they'll see that we're acting within the
law and we as a government will be
outlining our legal position and being
particularly about why this is
absolutely within the law so james eadie
is the first treasury council
effectively the government's top
independent legal adviser was he asked
whether this would break international
law i'm not going to get into the
internals of government advice that's
something we don't do but what i mean
it's important though isn't it because
there is a lot of people who look at
this and they think this is going to
break international law and actually
rather than just saying it's not going
to
it the government's going to show it's
working
i'll go further than saying it's not
going to when people see the legislation
tomorrow and the government's legal
position they will see that this is
working within the law so walter james
ede asked whether it would break
international law the government lawyers
are very clear this we are working
within the law the attorney general will
be setting out the government's legal
position on that tomorrow in line with
the bills
you don't have to even ask my word for
it you can see the bill tomorrow and you
will see that what we're doing is within
the law okay and i just guess
some people look at this might think
look last time you you tried to sort of
change the the protocol in order to
change the trade in northern ireland you
at least acknowledged that you would be
breaking the law no that didn't go so
that didn't go let's be clear no no that
was before the protocol was agreed in
the automotive yeah there was no brexit
deal there was no protocol what we were
setting out is what we would need to do
if there hadn't been an agreement so we
were taking an insurance policy and we
stood by our word and once we secured
that issue but you know we didn't take
that course you didn't you didn't take
the action um you're right um but you at
least acknowledged that it would be
breaking the law it feels like this time
you have effectively managed to to you
know that it's going to break the law
but you're just not being completely
honest with us oh no they're very
strange look and say as i say if you go
back to the point we were making at the
time we were being very clear that
rather than giving primacy to what was
at that point
no brexit deal no trade agreement and an
incomplete withdrawal agreement we were
going to give primacy to the belfast
group friday agreement what we are doing
now is fixing the issues within the
protocol we we accept we've always been
clear there needs to be a treaty
agreement protocol between us and the eu
we need to respect the single market
protect north south trade as well as
east west and strand one the institution
has a stomach and giving primacy to the
belfast good friday agreement we are
going to set out legislation tomorrow
that will do that within the law
in 2024 under the brexit deal
politicians in northern ireland will get
to vote on whether or not to keep the
protocol it's effectively the kind of
exit clause and it's northern ireland
politicians who get to make that
decision
is there anything in the bill tomorrow
that could override that no in 2024
there is a consent mechanism and a vote
for the politicians all that and one of
these i think gets missed sometimes is
debatable i guess all the political
parties in northern ireland at the
moment are clear the protocol in its
current stage doesn't work yeah i i want
to come back on that a little bit
because it's much more complicated than
that oh yeah
that does feel you know a slight um
people often talk about this as well as
one political party and that's not
actually fair all the party leaders have
been very clear both with me in public
but there's they need to be church
you would accept that 54 of the 90 newly
elected mlas think that the protocol
effectively should keep going that they
disagree with the idea that it should be
scrapped you can also be changed you can
also point to the majority of uh from
the parties that are designated
obviously there's a larger proportion of
those are unionist mlas and they're all
the unionist parties very clear they
want the protocol scrapped all together
what we're going to do is say set out
tomorrow how we can restore the
institutions of northern ireland by
fixing the problems that are there
should you not ask if if the principle
of consent is so important you know the
exit clause you say won't be um
overruled
should you not ask the politicians in
northern ireland to get their approval
if you like for any unilateral changes
that you're willing to make when you
know uh that actually you know the
majority of people on who'd been newly
elected 54 of the 90 don't want to see
it scrapped well there's also uh the
last wide poll on this that was done in
northern ireland a few months ago now
actually set out 78 of the population in
northern ireland i felt the protocol
wasn't working and needed to be fixed so
we as uk government have a
responsibility to resolve this issue for
all people in northern ireland
businesses and all the whole community
of northern which we're going to do
obviously we're in continual contact
with all of the political parties i talk
to all the party leaders regularly and
we do as a government
giving you an assurance that if there's
legislations go through that they will
they will rejoin power sharing no that's
a matter for the dup i would expect to
see the dup when they see us resolving
the issues of the protocol
following what they said was their
position which is as they see the
protocol issues being resolved that they
would restore these things you haven't
had that assurance but no that's a
matter for the dup i hope to see them go
back they should be going back i have to
say i would have liked to have seen them
being nominated to speak in a different
language
how long would you allow northern
ireland to go without an assembly before
calling another election well there's a
set piece of legislation now which gave
stability that came out of the new
decade new approach agreement we passed
that earlier this year that means that
the assembly has 24 weeks for the
parties to work together to find a a
program of government that they can
support and i've written to all the
parties to encourage them to come
together to the very least be doing that
work around a program of government
after 24 weeks then we have to take a
view about whether there is a further
election
uh now let's talk about immigration
shall we uh to send you want to send
asylum seekers to uh rwanda the
government won a battle in the high
court uh next week um last week sorry do
you expect that flight to take off on
tuesday yes
yes we do i think it was very good that
we won that uh court case that's one
stage of the process and i think
underlying this is actually a policy and
a program that huge credit to the home
secretary and the prime minister for
taking this forward because it's one
that makes it very clear to these
abhorrent people who run these modern
slavery schemes and this these
treacherous runs across the channel that
this business model will not work
if you're talking about if you're
talking about that it could be said that
this is actually incentive to bring
children with you over the seas isn't it
because then you won't get sent to
rwanda well no it's a very clear message
to the and this is part of a wider
package you're absolutely right there is
no silver bullet to deal with the issues
around illegal immigration these are
criminals who will always be looking at
what is the next thing but it is right
we're clear to them that we're going to
break that business model what they're
doing will not work like putting aside
the kind of government line
are you personally comfortable with this
policy yes i am actually and i think it
is right that we're very clear to people
there are a number of legal routes to
which people can come to this country
and that's important for two reasons one
is we've got to make sure that when
people come here we can give them the
proper support to be part of our society
but people are coming illegally we've
got to make sure that these vile gangs
know that that will not work and it's
not the right way to do it prince
charles has privately described the
policy as appalling and private comments
but they have of course appeared in the
newspapers are you comfortable with the
future king
openly talking about government policy
in this way well they're not just
private companies they're rumored
private comments i think it's uh i think
it's appropriate to comment on what
somebody says they might have heard
without any context of it the reality is
this is a policy that is going to
deliver to ensure that modern slavery
and these people smugglers know that
their criminal methods will be broken
down and saying to people around the
world if you are a refugee if you're
asylum seeker if you're a legal migrant
coming to this country we want to give
you the support to properly help you be
part of the uk economy part of the uk
way of life which is what you want and
that's right but we've got to do that in
a proper legal managed way and people
encouraging you to travel illegally are
wrong and we're going to break their
business model um we're facing a summer
of strikes the sunday telegraph uh
reporting that the government could
bring in agency staff in order to break
the strikes
um grant shap saying you're looking at
says you're looking at changing changing
the law to allow employers to
effectively use agency staff to break
strikes to cover for striking workers is
that true
well we're looking at as grant said look
today actually we're looking at a whole
range of things i think it's right that
we do that i think it's right that we
are looking at everything we can do to
support hard-working people who are
looking often to get to work get
children to school get to hospital
appointments not being disrupted by
strike action particularly in a sector
where i think the median pay in that
sector is almost double what the average
pay is for citizens in the uk
so i think it is right that we are on
the side of working people and that
grant is rightly looking at all the
options would that not be undermining
you know the people's right to strike i
think it's supporting the general
public's right to get to work to get to
emergency appointments to get to school
to live their everyday life as i say we
all talk about an industry as i say i
think the median salary is about 46 000
as opposed to an average salary in the
uk about 26 000. so i think it is right
that we are looking to support people
who are looking to go out everyday lives
in a normal way and they have a right to
do so it's been a
pretty difficult week for the prime
minister i'm sure you'll uh you know
acknowledge uh 41 conservative mps uh
voting to have no confidence him he's
announced his kind of policy blitz if
you like he's also hinted very strongly
at the prospect of tax cuts he's
described the current tax
burden as an aberration in tuesday's
cabinet he said we have the scope by
delivering tax cuts to deliver growth so
what kind of tax cuts can we expect well
actually i think what this week
highlights is the prime minister's
getting on with the job you know they're
we're continuing to work to deliver for
people across that level
in terms of tax cuts i'm a conservative
and i believe in a low tax economy i
think lower taxes is pretty unhappy with
the current situation well i think what
we've we've always got to talk about
but we're also making sure that as of
next month 70 of the population are
going to have a tax reduction through
the increase in the national threshold
we're making sure what but
we're making sure the businesses who are
making huge profits incentivized to use
that money to go into investment for the
future we've got to make sure that we're
using tax in a way that isn't fiscally
sensible because we have had an
exorbitant period through kovi where we
have supported the public that cost
money the war in ukraine that cost money
we've got to be sensible about this but
doing that in a way that creates a
foundation where we can bring in more
taxes so what kind of cuts would you
like it's a good thing for the united
kingdom
i'm not going to prejudge the chance
that's all no no no no
decisions the chancellor has to make but
even before this week the chancellor and
the prime minister were clear that as
soon as the fiscal situation allows
we've got to be very sensible about that
we're managing public money after all we
want to see tax cuts and the chance of
once bringing tax cuts in some poor
people have more money in their pocket
to spend how they know they can spend it
best i just want to end by a quote from
somebody that i spoke to on wednesday
when we on the wednesday night program
and we we basically talked to a focus
panel if you like of conservative voters
this is a guy called john commerford
he's a pensioner he's someone who
isolated at home during the pandemic he
wasn't able to go to the funeral of
loved ones
and he told me this he said i voted
conservative all my life
and i wouldn't even think about not
voting conservative but i cannot vote
for boris johnson i just won't vote at
all which at my age having voted ever
since i was 18 would actually disturb me
i mean this is a man who is effectively
desperate to vote conservative he can't
bring himself to vote for anyone else
he's always voted for conservative
parties since he was 18. he says he
cannot do it anymore
i mean it must be
you know for conservative mps like you
listening to that
it must be pretty upsetting
well i think it's a very clear reminder
of the work we've got to between now and
the next generation indeed depending on
where he lives in the potentially local
elections next year to convince people
like john yeah okay so he's probably
mayor will have district elections even
next year our work and the focus for us
has to be on working to ensure we can
earn his vote at the next election
because it's important for prime
minister that he can't vote yeah and
actually yeah and i would and i would
like to think that as he will see over
the next year or so as the prime
minister is focused on delivering for
people in the united kingdom giving a
better life for people in the future
that he is the right man to lead us into
that next generation i think he is and i
hope the people like john are the sort
of people will be able to convince to
continue to vote for them all breaking
even tomorrow sorry no more law breaking
even tomorrow we're going to be working
within the law but we are importantly
going to fix a problem that has been
detrimental to the lives of people in
north london we have a duty to do that
and it's right that we do it okay thank
you very much